you excited to spend a day with your
friend yeah are you here what's going up
huh laughter yeah yeah
okay good morning today is an exciting
day Isaac's friend is coming over so she
goes to school with his little friend
named Mikey Mikey's mom Lindsey she's
actually a friend of mine too so they're
both coming over the plan for today is
to go just bowling and then maybe after
some laser tag so it's going to be a fun
day for the kids especially since
they're on their summer break we're
trying to keep them busy with some
activities so let's go see what Isaac is
up to right now look he he upgraded his
room now it's Hollywood into the sisters
room welcome to Hollywood
whoa hey baby what are you doing I'm
retired he taught me yesterday oh I put
it on my Instagram story so it was like
next journey
Casey's teaching Isaac how to tie a tie
you want to tie it here not you don't
want to go here you want to do it up
here okay so it's closer to your neck
okay I mean you have to look look with
this book okay as you can see I upgrade
in my room oh yeah show them they
haven't seen this yet oh right here is
my little library aka Clubhouse Casey
bought me a fan over there right there
so I could be a cooler I bet I always
gets hot over here and right there is my
lamp and my alarm clock then you have
all your books down here huh
you little messy boy you have some
clothes yeah why'd you decide to do this
before I planned you to make this whole
room of big clip up but can I take a
while yeah I didn't did this for
construction beeping I know he's been
sleeping on this couch for the past I
don't know how long like maybe like a
month yeah like who else but yeah this
bed is just been a lonely bed huh yeah
all right
well Isaac guess what what I have a
surprise for you Oh
calm down I'll show you once you get
downstairs I want to know it okay hurry
up finish your tiles meet you downstairs
good
hey baby a good morning you have to be
resting editing we're falling behind on
fog did you see what came in the mail
some cool stuff and then we'll see what
we got yeah it's pretty much Christmas
are you guys ready to see what came in
the mail
yeah big changes Alexis I really think
so do you guys remember of people weeks
ago we were on glasses usa.com and we
were testing out their try on mirror
where we uploaded our photo and then we
got to see which glasses will look
better thank you remember that I did it
for you remember I was like look guys
like with glasses do you want and you
pick to use out another here turn up I
asked what is it does this video is in
collaboration with glasses usa.com
and so a couple weeks ago we were online
we're picking out which classes we
wanted and Isaac have been needing
prescription glasses for a while oh I
remember now you're another here and I'm
so excited because I've never seen you
with glasses on before except for the
fact that woman went to go get your
prescription oh yeah and the doctor gave
you remember those like weird funky
looking back there scientist glasses
yeah science is but alright so let's see
what we got here you have the knees open
there's your open that oh these are
yours
you just blew mine look love it yeah
these are both sizes
oh my god do prescription glasses look
at you too and blue tags with sure blue
glasses I see very clear
that feeling I remember when I first got
glasses I was missing the fourth grade -
you're about to be in the fourth grade
and the [ __ ] new pairs of
prescription glasses yeah we got the
baller through lots of - oh one more
thing
oh you can go in for them you look like
a big kid you like these um yeah you can
grab the naval save them to people so
Casey and I we don't need prescription
glasses anymore - we've got LASIK but we
still picked out some to show you guys
did I miss one this is dope I'm gonna
keep this one you did pick it out yeah
hoping your mind everything you see
there's a pretty awesome beads that I
thought are the Amelia II London glasses
you can check out the links in the
description box below we've linked all
of these glasses Isaac you've got the
Emerson glasses just you're wearing
right here fancy yeah ours the muse and
five three seven one so it's pretty
awesome we have like two thousand five
hundred pairs of glasses on their site
and have name brands as well as like
their in-house brands like these are
there in health friends so I think this
was really really cool because it's
actually doubles as prescription and
sunglasses so these come off and then
you can be like hey but I love
description them oh those look awesome
all those glasses glasses yeah but so
since we don't need prescription we
actually gone with zero so they don't
have any prescription these are just
cool hipster glasses hollingers you're
the real you're the real deal yeah I
think you look super super cute you was
really gonna do you want to make me wish
that we didn't campaign
these are actually be nears m806 one
yeah if you guys check out the links in
the description you guys will get a
super great offer for getting your first
pair of glasses so make sure to check
out those I want to be like I'm going to
get these lenses maybe change that for
computer glasses and we can actually
yeah we're not closed Serbia we like to
make it more functional you're good
there the air clean babies they're brand
new glasses I think their cousin so it's
also awesome about less and very calm is
that they have name-brand glasses like
these babies here so I've been wanting
the pair of ray-bans for so long look
awesome yeah so these are the Ray Ban
three zero one six Club pattern Casey
you're wearing the rabe and two one
three two new Wayfarer so it's really
cool case glasses usa.com cuts up the
middle man and they offer prescription
glasses for up 70% off retail prices
yeah a good deal too sizes are so as we
got to for I think yeah you came up
buddy I know yeah yeah you don't look
like Isaac anymore so I'm not baby
anymore who's got the time in my hair
and the glasses you're so fancy I do
your fancy okay all right look like a
chicken ripped yeah yeah yeah so check
out all right so now we're just going to
be waiting for Lindsey and Mikey to get
here and then we're going to take off
but sorry dude you're gonna stay home
because you got work to do lots of work
I would I kind of want to just worried
should I just wear them being opposed to
this yeah I'm gonna wear them okay or
four I'd like a try it's a change of
plans
we got to go pick up Lindsey picking up
Lindsey and your boyfriend Adam and then
from there we go ahead to go pick up
Ikey because apparently you slipped over
his crab shells and then after we're
going to go get some lunch and then do
the laser tag and then do the bowling
are you excited yes I'm very excited
leader types very very slow like
dream Hey look at this good-looking
couple
okay oh yeah whatever is a jacket oh
we're broke you finally got your barbell
jacket back forever I left them so do
you think Isaac got new glasses I love
them Thank You looks like this big kid
huh you guys all right so this is
Lindsey and Adam okay all right so you
guys excited for a day solar it's nice
let's go get Mikey
oh hey let's go hey Mike you here hi
Mikey you look so handsome thank you do
you want to stay in the back of my cute
Lindsay like over friends come on come
on
yeah grows on the front boys on the back
hold your time it you're not a good
you're excited for some grub yeah all
right yeah yeah Worf right one right
there you push me listen to the kids
conversation and just be like man it is
kind of nostalgic isn't it yeah so cute
okay because I'm like imagine if we do
this and imagine if I do that random
yeah it's so cute I remember being that
age you will be gay
thank you will be excited to eat hat
real man
yeah you cook it you know what are you
top six now yes
have you learned her every name list
let's mama her mommy or mom or mama you
call her by her first name
I'm gonna
[Music]
it's clickbait go use it what's quickly
false advertisement Isaac always called
it a ripoff you're gonna eat your tongue
I'm using slop oh oh the you know the
car is sorry you should learn from him
at the Toyota Center on it there will be
all your nose Toyotas
[Music]
high level are you cooking
yeah like cooking for us boy with those
big boy glasses now look at you cooking
and everything you don't want any meat
my teeth really wake up is I kind of
weirding you out that the meat is coming
out raw and then you have to yourself
really their friend from school so he's
taking advice from his friend from
school bus pass and look please
[Music]
she likes serving us baby
you like cooking so polite eyes are
leaving Korean barbecue now but look at
what these kids are up soon what's
happening here here's so funny to lug
this get up let's go baby pack now
[Music]
how can you carry your strong my feet
how do you do that you go my back yeah
what if I want to do that
let's see that exactly you're ready no
Falls get impressed
hahaha yes
oh yeah are you ready okay
hammer away and I got to play bye guys
oh my gosh girls I cannot get anybody
like everybody I was aiming at they were
just like easy target throwing the
camera yes so the thing is like with
these laser guns you have to use both of
your hands in order to shoot what since
I wasn't able to use my close to my hand
I just kept getting hit like crazy
I think the kids had fun that's all that
matters alright so that was it relays
are tagged did you guys have fun yeah
you guys ready for bowling yeah very
true it is what you're gonna be Isaac
yeah want me to do that
I have small fingers Isaac goes to I
think I dream cars or drew you can't
quite optimally so Adam has to go pick
up his son so that's why he's not with
us right now but we're gonna have some
fun
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so the kids have been dying to
come to Bowl what you wanted a bowl what
happened oh yeah by the way a little
update on those brand new students that
we bought him in Paris look at them now
well they're navy blue any more friends
will be boys
alright let me know you guys want a bowl
Lindsey and I will wait over here so
they're just playing over there or grab
a chair
[Music]
now you want to pull I just that down
by falling she's already [ __ ] you
wanna try shoot what's happening what's
happening
nice try
that's how you roll thank you gave up
you got dizzy you okay bad aren't you
hot
take this off what maybe we shouldn't
rolling I wanna be happy crazy
he's so hyper all right looks like
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're getting the bumper so
we're not professionals yeah me neither
here we go our bumpers are coming thank
you now we can play
[Music]
see thank you guys are so silly
hey b-boying now what are you still
singing are you being the mob for the
bowling alley
[Music]
Oh are used to crazy ready to crazy all
right
our day is now guys like our little [ __ ]
lady
Yeah right yes and oh yes is laser tag
has lawn bowling why are you choking
sighs it is however very good today
yesterday it was a bit yeah I'm glad you
had fun
are you guys ready for more of these fun
days for your summer break yeah all
right let's go take you guys home now
good night what Isaac there's chairs
everywhere else come on
Aundre cheese and deli did you see our
blog yeah what'd you think of it you
have any of your own inventions that
you've tried yet what what have you
[Music]